for the best picture of the year the
members of the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences nominated these five
darling and amalgamated production
Embassy Joseph geni producer and Doctor
Zhivago aiso star metro-goldwyn-mayer
British Studios production
metro-goldwyn-mayer Carlo Ponti producer
The Sound of Music and Argyle
enterprises production 20th Century Fox
Robert Wise Verdes
and ship of fools Columbia Pictures
Stanley Kramer producer and finally A
Thousand clowns The Herald production
United Artists Fred co-producer
The Sound of Music Robert Wise
accepting the best picture award for
Robert Wise is Saul chaplain
I'm proud to accept this on behalf of
Robert Wise I'm sure if he were here he
would first want to thank the members of
the Academy he would also I think want
to thank everybody connected with making
a film
I can only say as one of them those
members I would like to thank him for
making filmmaking such a rewarding and
stimulating experience thank you very
much
you
you
thank you John
well that's about it from mad mad mad
mad Hollywood to you winners
congratulations and the rest of you form
a line and I shall lead you to the
Mickey Rooney School of Acting I have a
credit card there the opinions expressed
on this program tonight are those of the
Academy but the final decision is up to
you at the box office
you make us or break us you're the final
arbiter the Supreme Court for in popcorn
sales there is truth our program has
been brought to you through the courtesy
of your neighborhood field be it drivin
a hardtop droppin them our night and ask
for them by name movies the instant
dream they're available in all sizes and
in a wide range of colors I'm grateful
for the part which I've been allowed to
play in the motion picture industry and
for what it is done for me it has helped
me support my government in the manner
to which it has become accustomed
it is a truly wonderful inner problems
never before in history has been a
medium with such potential on at the
same time such great responsibility but
we have access as never before to the
minds and hearts of people and
especially the young I'm proud to be
connected with a great power there was
motion pictures it is definitely a force
and a force for good and so until next
year at the same time this meeting of
the Great Society stands adjourned thank
you and good night
you